okay so here's the premise you're moored
at your computer and you think man these
anime youtubers have it made maybe I can
live the Rockstar dream and swimming
YouTube cash like the rest of them lol
so you make a video shooting on sword
art online you put us on the sweet ass
as a thumbnail I'm boom you've made it
big you've got views you've got the subs
and social blood he's telling you that
you should be at least making 100k per
year so you get your first paycheck
through the door excited about your
prospects as an eventual millionaire and
you see that a check is 10 cents [ __ ] so
you start to think to yourself how am I
ever gonna make money doing anime videos
then it comes to you the answers been
staring at you right under your nose
this entire time but you've just never
noticed it everyone else has been doing
it from getting super successful but
you've told yourself that you can never
join their ranks but now you know it's
the only thing that you can do today
you're me animate so not pretend the top
10 hottest anime woman ever
hi I'm Giga can I've started a patreon
whoa whoa hold on before you leave I've
actually done a ton of research and why
I am running the perfect patreon
campaign am i tons of research I mean
there's one document I got from patreon
about how to run a campaign so by the
end it's guaranteed that you should all
be ready to give a small donation of at
least 1 million dollars each so let's
see here what is patreon oh ok so
firstly I guess I'm supposed to explain
what patreon is because people
definitely don't know what it's about
already from the millions of different
youtubers using it it's a crowdfunding
website where you can support me for
[ __ ] on your favorite anime for
talking about your favorite anime you
donate however many dollars you want i
[ __ ] out more videos you're happy and I
get to buy five more Lamborghinis that's
my collection it's that simple
now it's important absolutely everybody
making a patreon campaign stresses that
it's not a mandatory thing to donate
because wanting money is a bad thing on
the internet so people need to act like
they don't like having money even if
they do so um so hit hit here I go oh no
I really don't want to take anyone's
money yeah I don't like having this
money no [ __ ] off it's my tell my
stories okay so why am I on patreon in
the first place because I like money
[ __ ] I've [ __ ] up the first point
already now most people would go on to
explain that the more money they raise
the more they can focus on videos and
maybe making this their job
see how I'm completely different from
those flips since I've already
preemptively quitted my well-paying job
cuz
[ __ ] idiots so I could explain to my
traditional Asian parents and making
stupid ad made videos on the interwebs
was a lifelong dream and a viable career
path comparable to being a doctor a
lawyer or a prostitute
hi mom do you know what a YouTube is
milestone goals okay let me see I got
this if you help me reach my ultimate
goal of ten million dollars then I will
personally flood Japan so I can fund one
punch man - [ __ ] no season two spy some
wolf season three and then kick Quintero
Miura up the ass so he can make more
berserk chapters hashtag make enemy
great again boom done that's all you
kids like see nowadays right next point
why should you support my poor life
decisions well aside from allowing me to
continue what I'm doing without having
to quit YouTube and go back to my job
there are a couple of ideas I've been
sitting on for ages that I could never
complete by myself and if I'm able to
even come close to the goals to making
them a reality then I'll reveal them
closer to the day but before we get to
that you could also help me make videos
faster will you Sookie maybe makes
enough money do you think you'll bring
back Ava bridge I hope but don't forget
if you donate more you get excited
reward okay so actually try to add
proper incentives for my different
reward tiers but I know half of you have
poor college students anyway so while in
the ideal world I would apply to most
people's reaction to my base should be
something like this oh my god I'm so
near what we should wonder I think I can
go for behind-the-scenes [ __ ] these
people you're suggesting then I'll get
[ __ ] you can't like I love [ __ ]
care that you're creating do you pay
things every day okay Kevin you're
actually pretty good come on come on
become a patron already come on Andy's
given my money but is another faster way
than this that work yeah that probably
works realistically if your boss didn't
he can't even afford food it's cool but
even if you're considering donating a
spare one dollar to the cause it'd be
much appreciated
I mean we all know you're gonna piss
away next month's budget from getting
shit-faced on the next party or new you
ever watch your skin so you can jerk off
the traits as glorious as that's exactly
what student loans are for anyway
disclaimer student loans I'm not
actually for poor life decisions and
that's--it's
I have now followed this document to a
tee so while it's scientifically proven
fact you should now be willing to donate
my patreon so uh here we go
hi Dave can I have my job back please
sohave you know it didn't mean to call
you a [ __ ] when I quit the ladies have
been clamoring for my Gendo train please
please never say that again